vous avez tous etc semaine de vacances
vous allez à tous une semaine de
vacances et je vous ai demandé d'amener
un objet qui symbolise vos vacances pour
les téléspectateurs
alors allons-y et après on bien sûr on
aura une merveille une merguez pepy 40k
merguez du maroc
ah oui apparemment donc il est allé au
maroc est actuellement est encore un
cadeau d'ailleurs alors je ne veux pas
savoir d'où vient cette peur games met
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour annoncer au
maroc et aux marocains que je vais moins
me rendre à partir de maintenant est
dorénavant pourquoi parce que en fait je
me suis rendu compte de ça que je suis
moi euh quoi nous donnons aux prises
mais je suis là bas la personnalité la
plus célèbre après le roi n'ont donc
quand je retourne au prix mais je vous
promets et l'ont pris pour la reine
labarthe a tenté le whisky c'est
passionnant parce qu'on veut savoir à
des prix si jamel c'est vrai qu'elle
m'allait oui oui de sauvegarder moitié
c'est vraiment moi comme je reconnais je
vous représente appelant lol l'ambassade
on va dire d'ambassadeur du maghreb
quand je vais là-bas ils m'accueillent à
l'aéroport j'ai demandé d'aidé face
parce je fais pas là que tous en a une
c'est dorment aussi de leur monnaie
ça arrive ça arrive et c'est formidable
quand on est alors j'ai des bretelles et
on invite à chaque restaurant alors je
peux plus sortir je suis à l'aise sur la
place ça a été une émeute on arrive aux
jeunes des gosses vacances donc je me
suis dit il faut que je trouve un pays
où un endroit où on ne connaissent moins
pour apprécier quand même les vacances
et l'anonymat comme franck marescal
oui je te bénis oui nos rames
je vous aime et ramenez nous les moules
dont michel vous connaissez vous allez
tenter de le rater j'ai ramené une
mouche ce que j'ai mangé une moule pas
fraîche pendant les vacances
ouais et du coup j'ai été malade
[Rires]
j'aimerais qu'on fait voici un tiers
qu'avec jean luc lemoine parce qu'il n'a
hainaut dans jamais jean luc je voudrais
ramener la plus belle
oui oui allez va bien jean luc hallé j
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
alors mathieu ya une théorie sur agathe
et enora ont dit toute la vérité icd
pendant la pub on dit les choses se
gâtent un petit peu mais pas trop bah
non j'ai pas de doré à l'or s'est dit en
tout cas vous pensez qu'elle vous voilà
s'apprécie également s'apprécier
je vois là je pense qu'elles vont
s'apprécier je pense qu'ils ont plein de
choses sentimentalement en commun oui
voilà que je veux dire non mais je pense
je peux me tromper je demande pas de
répondre sinon j'ai la réponse est je
pense qu agathe et aime bien l'amour au
sens large du terme parce que les vicois
merci le mec au départ était chose moi
ce que j'aimerais qu'elle est vrai que
c'est pas si mathieu d'accord avec moi
j'aimerais qu'on ait agathe et nora qui
opposera thouars qu avec lexie
[Applaudissements]
à
alexis
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est moi les deux vous savez prix
des rideaux de douche pour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
car il s'est pourtant rouiba n'y en a
qu'un petit bourgogne ici c'est que
ségolène royal c'est un peu ma came au
moment où c'était mon délire c'est lé
monde et d'infirmières ce genre de meuf
voyager quand même il ya combien de
temps j'étais mort il ya deux ans non
pas devant l'autre depuis je suis donc
celle à l'excision par des bouées ou
quoi à la radio c'était bon délire
ségolène royal s'était livrée à payer de
prix jolly haut mais je vous le dis
ouais ouais ouais vous plaît si cette
femme mais c'est vrai que physiquement
je fais un pro dans le chapeau elle y
est les classes c'est vrai que les gars
aient les excuses moi vous voulez vous
parler mais je vais vous la pyramide sud
et donc et donc vous pas l'arrivée des
grands et des grands elle est
intelligente et des finances ailleurs
j'aime bien les femmes en tailleur dans
le sens du mot shoah comment m'habiller
alors mathieu c'est une question sur
l'amour en plus pour rester dans le
thème autres vous dites que vous avez
des sentiments pour cyril est ce parce
que c'est votre boss ou bien s'il avait
été un banal vendeur de roses
est ce qu'on voulait marier au temps
mais ça on a une petite idée de la
réponse merci la belge est très sympa à
ma soeur agathe on voit que tu ne
connais vraiment rien à l'amour pour
poser ce genre de question de dire que
même si ça avait été mon chauffeur ça
pourrait l'être dans quelques années on
ferait mais parfois les retourne on sait
jamais même si dans un ou deux ans je
devais récupérer cette émission ou de
venir lui dire de la chaîne ou peu
importe si tu deviens mon chauffeur
parce que je ne serai pas tomber je te
laisserai jamais tomber toute une
famille je ne serai pas tomber je
t'aimerai autant toujours autant c'est
beau roman
[Applaudissements]
hu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or m
à
c'est un poste où
[Applaudissements]
je récupère
faire